[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Print a haiku.
That's really good.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't see you there.
I was just talking to
my receipt printer.
I know what you're
thinking, but this printer
uses the Google Assistant SDK to
print out text and images based
on voice commands I'm
going to tell you just
how easy it is to get started
with using the Google Assistant
SDK to build
voice-interactive printers,
signage, or anything
else you can think of.
The Google Assistant SDK allows
developers to build hardware
with the Google Assistant
embedded inside of it.
Users can talk to it in
any supported language
and the assistant will
give a response that
can be presented to the user.
When you're building
a device, there
will be certain
types of actions that
only makes sense
when you're speaking
to a particular hardware
device in front of you.
In order to support
these advanced use cases,
we're introducing
Custom Device Actions.
Custom Device Actions
allow developers
to create their own
specific set of actions
within the Google
Assistant interface,
and allow users to interact
with it in a more natural way.
You can specify a number of
phrases that match, along
with a set of standard
parameters or custom parameters
that you define.
For example, you can create a
custom parameter of type shape.
There are many types
of shapes that you can
print, like a star or a box.
You can define more than one
action, such as a second action
that prints haikus.
You can set up a
variety of phrases
that may activate your action--
print a star, print the
box, show me a haiku.
All of these actions are
defined in the action package.
You can use the gactions
tool to deploy them.
Your action package can also
contain more than one action.
To trigger an action, it
requires certain query patterns
that your users must say.
When that happens, you can
define the fulfillment.
This may include a simple speech
response, as well as execution
of a callback on your device.
Each action can
contain parameters,
in this case a shape.
A shape can be defined with
a particular key as well
as several synonyms.
In our application, we will
need to add the device model
and instance identifiers
before each request.
When the user utterance matches
one of the defined grammars,
a custom device
action is activated.
Your application will receive
a structured JSON payload that
includes the action to
run and all the parameters
the user has said.
From this you can
complete your action.
You'll still get all the
Google Assistant capabilities
in machine learning and
natural language understanding.
What time is it?
And here's a demo of a
custom device action.
Print a star.
I can also say something
like print a handsome person.
What?
What the heck?
That's me.
Oh my goodness.
That's so nice.
I hope this video
was helpful to you
for getting started with
custom device actions.
Read our documentation
to learn more.
Join our community to discuss
this with other developers,
and make sure to subscribe
to this channel for more
awesome videos about
the Google Assistant.
[MUSIC PLAYING]